[Music]
well you have been listening there to
representatives from the united arab
emirates bahrain
and israel all speak the two arab
countries foreign ministers
and israeli prime minister benjamin
netanyahu this is all ahead
of signing a deal to normalized ties all
of us on the south lawn of the white
house and as you can see they're
overseen today by a very proud u.s
president donald trump
donald trump has been describing today a
signing of what they're calling these
abraham accords as the dawn of a new
middle east
and president trump congratulated all
the different parties and he
says that he is optimistic confident
even that other countries
will follow and then we had israeli
prime minister benjamin netanyahu
also saying that this could potentially
end the arab-israeli conflict
once and for all still though the
bahraini foreign minister insisting that
there is the potential for a two-state
solution that this
does take them one step closer however
palestinians
as we've been hearing from our
correspondents in the west bank and then
also in the protesters
in the crowd just outside the white
house saying that they do feel like this
is
the end of any potential peace process
between the arabs and the israelis in
the middle east
and that there is a deep and profound
sense of betrayal
and anger that this is taking place
today
well it does look like they're about to
sit down and sign that deal
uh white house correspondent kimberly
halcott is there on the lawn with them
and we will be speaking
to her as this all happened united
states the prime minister
of the state of israel and his science
the minister of foreign affairs
and international cooperation of the
united arab emirates
will sign a treaty of peace diplomatic
relations
and full normalization they will each
sign
three copies one in english hebrew
and arabic we kindly ask that all guests
remain seated for the signing of the
documents
[Music]
well let's bring in our white house
correspondent kimberly halcott who is
standing there on the lawn watching
all of this happen as it takes place
live now kimberly you were saying
earlier this has been regarded as a
really important moment but not
necessarily
a historic deal talk us through the
significance of what we're seeing
right now
i think it's significant and certainly
many people will argue that this is
historic given the fact that this
is uh sitting down of
regional neighbors who have not sat down
recently in front of the white house in
this manner and so
this is being heralded at least by the
participants as historic
it was important to note that all of the
leaders seem to call for a
departure of cynicism that they're
trying to see this as a template for
moving forward
in a dawn of a new era of peace in the
middle east now
notable is that the palestinians are not
present for this in terms of the
israeli-palestinian conflict
but even that we are told that
in terms of the agreement has prevented
further annexation of palestinian land
something that the foreign minister of
uae acknowledged was
particularly important so whether
hopeful is that this will allow for
other arab nations to also
normalize their relations so that is
something that is being celebrated
recognizing that there are still many
other nations to join onto this
agreement but in terms of the message
that's being sent i think it's important
that to acknowledge that the
israeli leader speaking in arabic at one
point
saying salaam alaikum this is certainly
an acknowledgement and overture if you
will of reaching out
that they say is very important well
kimberly
when we were speaking earlier you
mentioned that there is more
international interest in what's
happening today than perhaps domestic
interest that average americans aren't
necessarily
watching this super closely what sort of
reaction have we been seeing there
especially in the lead up to this deal
which we
we knew was going to be signed today
i'm sorry it's a little bit distracting
to hear what you're saying as
i'm also hearing the loudspeaker in my
ear but what i can tell you is happening
right now is of course the fact that
they
are in a very momentous occasion all of
these leaders signing
these documents it's important to note
that they are being signed in three
different languages
in english in hebrew and also
in arabic and that is really significant
in terms of the partnership and this
recognition that all of the people of
abraham as you heard one of the speakers
saying
now able to move forward to bring
stability and prosperity they say to the
middle east
also saying in there that with the
abraham accords and they're signing that
in fact
all muslims will now be able to go to
pray at al-aqsa mosque of course the
third holiest site
for islam and this is a significant
achievement and also the fact that
they feel that many in the region were
held back by old conflicts particularly
the younger generations so these
senior generations now trying to show an
example
setting aside some of those conflicts to
give the opportunities
for not just prosperity but even
scientific achievement
so the best and the brightest in the
region regardless of religion
regardless of language spoken will now
have that opportunity
kimberly i was asking you ellie and i
know it's very allowed there just around
the reaction that you've been seeing
from the different political factions
in the us how are they regarding this
deal
well it's notable that uh in the midst
of this event actually taking place
right now that
what they're focusing on is not reaction
but the moment itself
that is what is taking place and
certainly that is what
we'll make it onto the television
screens but there's no question with the
coming hours that there will be reaction
we know that there was some cautious
optimism
by the top uh house of representatives
leader nancy pelosi who
said that she felt this was an important
day but also a day that
congress will need to scrutinize in
terms of future deals
with regard to arms sales and in fact we
know from the palestinian palestinian
negotiator that in fact i'm just trying
to keep an eye about what's going on
keep one ear
as i talk to you that there is a fear
that
this is an ushering in of an arms race
and there certainly are going to be
questions about potential sales of f-35
fighter jets to
the uae that is one thing that congress
is watching very carefully but there's
also concern that this in some way
legitimizes
some of the concerns with respect to
human rights and the contributions the
uae has played
in the conflict with regard to yemen and
u.s support for that conflict the
saudi-led conflict there which
of course we know the united nations is
called a humanitarian disaster there's
also the pro-democracy movement
in the uae and whether or not the
quashing of that
has somehow been legitimate given
legitimacy
in this deal so there is going to be a
reflection in the coming days but
certainly again these leaders asking
that that cynicism be set aside so that
they can focus on
what they see as the future for the
younger generations as heralded through
this deal
and a template for peace they hope that
other arab nations will sign on to
kimberly you mentioned the armor sales
there there has been a lot of talk of
economic and security ties as well as
the practical implications like being
able
to go and worship at alexa there has
been a lot of speculation
around how this might change regional
dynamics
and a lot of talk about how this really
paints
iran in the region as as the kind of
mutual enemy
of all the groups here how might this
affect
foreign policy going forward in in the
region
for all these different countries
[Applause]
well there's some cynicism that in fact
it doesn't change anything at all that
this is really just a
show that in fact the posturing
against iran already was in place that
there were already informal
exchanges in terms of a united concern
about iran between the uae and israel as
well as bahrain
and that this is just an advance of the
election an opportunity to formalize
that and give the u.s president
a win that he might need on the foreign
policy stage so many would argue that
nothing has changed of course there are
others that will view this as a
provocation and that's certainly
something that i put forward to
jason greenblatt in terms of how iran
could
react and they said that the
administration sees
in their view that iran sees everything
as a provocation
and that that is no reason for them to
not move forward but certainly that is a
concern in the us congress in fact it
will be the subject of an upcoming
hearing
with respect to not only the weapons
sales but how those will be utilized and
the u.s role in that
so you've heard the leaders here today
say that the u.s has a very firm
footprint and that it is one that should
be recognized
uh but again it is always as it has been
in the past and will be in the future
one that is controversial indeed
kimberly we're seeing everyone on the
balcony there looking very very
happy indeed and particularly president
trump looking very proud
you mentioned the timing of this 49 days
to the election
can president trump expect a boost from
this
it's unlikely that the domestic audience
is going to be paying much attention to
this this really has more to do
with geo politics and realignment there
but in terms of foreign policy circles
in the united states and in the u.s
congress that will certainly be
recognized
it's something that the u.s can the u.s
president can put in his campaign
commercials
but again it's not a focus of ordinary
americans what they're concerned about
is the economy kitchen table issues like
making sure there's a job that their
children are safe to go back to school
in the midst of a pandemic
those are the issues that will be
important but
again in terms of sort of the larger
scope of
creating a checklist of wins for this
president certainly this is one that he
will add
whether or not this will win over any
new voters is unclear
but certainly it is something the u.s
president felt was important enough to
put
in advance of the us election as one of
his in his view
foreign policy achievements our white
house correspondent kimberly halcott
watching that event for us that very
very landmark deal being signed
on the south lawn of the white house
there thank you very much kimberly
well just outside the white house
protesters
have gathered against that deal
[Music]
palestinian americans are calling it
traitorous and they say they've been
left out of efforts towards peace
our correspondent heidi joe castro is
with those protesters there
heidi we were seeing competing protests
earlier clashes almost
emotions are clearly running high there
that's right and you'll notice the
palestinian flag
unfurl behind me namely the one flag
missing
from the ceremonies we've seen taking
place within the white house and that
really encapsulates the sense of
betrayal being left aside that these
palestinian-american protesters
have been expressing to me they are few
there's a few dozen people here they're
joined by some
jewish allies and other allies but they
certainly
have been vocal now staging a press
conference outside of the press house
earlier they walked around the block
kept at a wide berth
from the proceedings there by police in
secret service but there was
a few moments of tense uh friction when
they encountered some
pro deal uh counter protesters we'll
hear from those folks in a moment but
first
this is what a man told me who is
palestinian american
drove here with his family from chicago
that's a 12
hour drive to be here he said to bear
witness to this moment
which he calls a betrayal and a great
disappointment
when our brothers the emirates
and the bahrain comes here to sign a
disagreement with israel
they can also sign a peace agreement
with the palestinian
the palestinian is the brothers they
deserve to have a peace too
and they're there to have a live too
they deserve to have to tell israel okay
give them some of the just to live
peace with you without a palestinian
problem to be resolved
there is no peace will be in the middle
east i didn't vote for him in
in 16 i'm definitely voting for him in
2020 because
of his awesome stance on israel um
like he's the best foreign policy
president we've had in
in generations
and that last protester the last voice a
counter protester who was speaking of
his
newfound support for president trump as
kimberly halcott was saying that this
move just within two months of the us
elections here
may be part of the campaign strategy
of president trump at least he's won one
new voter there
but certainly on the minds of average
americans here this has not been
front page news here in the u.s and
whether or not this
helps move the needle into as we near
the election
in trump's favor is still to be seen
heidi joe castro they're just outside
the white house in washington d.c for us
thank you very much heidi
well palestinians have also been
protesting in gaza and the occupied west
bank our correspondent
ibrahim is there and joins us live from
ramallah nida when we were spoken
when we spoke earlier you mentioned that
the deep level of anger there
have people been watching the signing
take place
not around me we didn't see people
watching it and we didn't see people
posting a lot on social media lately
namely because many of them have been
saying that this is not surprising that
uh if some arab states are normalizing
with israel
but they weren't expecting that the
timing of it would be
so close to the american plan that the
this administration has been pushing for
the u.s has been trying to get the
palestinians
to sign and to agree on the
the u.s mideast peace plan which
palestinians see
as a plan that doesn't meet any of their
aspirations
for a future state they feel that the
palestinians here feel that they were
betrayed
by the arabs they feel like this is a
failure by the palestinian diplomacy
and that the palestinian leadership has
lost its regional and arab allies many
officials have told us that
these two agreements wouldn't have been
signed uh today without the approval
of regional powers so they feel like
they stand alone
and many officials have said that this
is the the
today considers that that they consider
today
as the as a black day and uh the death
declaration of the arab peace initiative
which calls for the normalization
between
of relations between israel and the arab
states but only when israel ends
its occupation of the palestinian lands
well nida we heard the emirati foreign
minister today ahead of that signing
thank
israel for halting the annexation of
palestinian territories
is there a belief on the ground there
that they will keep their promise and
for how long
on the contrary for the palestinians
they don't really
care if there is a an announcement of
halting annexation
because for them the israeli measures on
the ground uh
when it comes to house demolitions when
it comes to annexing lands and trying to
push palestinians out
of their lands in the occupied west bank
are still ongoing so
even if israel has delayed its uh
uh plans to annex parts of the occupied
west bank
business goes as usual when it comes to
the
actions of the israeli government in the
occupied territory
so for them really they didn't gain
anything from the uae's deal with israel
and they also said that the bahraini
deal didn't give even
anything not even a kind of a statement
to save faith that they
did that for the palestinian people they
don't want
anyone to be taking credit or to give
give
them and to show that they did that for
the palestinians they say we don't want
anyone to speak
on our behalf this is a message we've
heard from many protesters in ramallah
today
nida this has clearly also brought a
number of the palestinian factions much
closer together has this helped with
unity there
there is definitely a move towards unity
palestinians leaders
palestinian leaders have been saying
that they really have
the way forward for them is to go inward
they really have no support
among a lot of the arab countries that
they were hoping that they would support
them
so they organized their leadership
meeting and
it was attended by hamas and islamic
jihad
officials and they agreed to renew steps
towards the palestinian reconciliation
between namely between fateh and hamas
but also between the occupied west bank
and the gaza strip
but it's worth noting that palestinians
who were interviewed in a poll released
today
there are around 60 and more than 60 of
them do not believe that
these reconciliation efforts will be
fruitful namely because it's been
more than 13 years on the palestinian
split and the palestinians are not
uh they had signed so many agreements to
reconcile
but uh they never did
nida ibrahim there for us and the
occupied west bank live for us in
ramallah thanks so much nida
well earlier i spoke to marjorie bezuari
he is director of the gulf study center
at qatar university and
he explains why this alliance between
the uae
bahrain and israel will not benefit the
palestinian cause
what is the importance of having these
relations at this
time um if there is no benefit to the
palestinians
the israeli context is coming because of
the palestinian cause
any arab countries wanted to have a
relation with israel
should be based on basically uh
finding a solution to the palestinian
request
so if the if this not the the outcome
it it's obvious that you know it's a
sort of
move toward coalition it's uh it is
most you know it's it's about survival
of this um mess political messer in the
region
where at least the only remember it was
part of it and
as well so i think it comes in a context
where
where they are losing a lot of uh
battles that they
put themselves in especially in yemen in
in libya and they are trying to find
basically victory and that this applies
on netanyahu this applies on
uh uh donald trump all of those parties
they are looking for short-term victory
and the real victim is the palestinian
cause on palestinian rights